[Applause]
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive the sun shining the birds are
singing
you're alive another day to impose your
will on these [ __ ] [ __ ] uncle Joey
here for the Monday morning motivation
what can I [ __ ] say you got the world
by the balls you're young me I'm an old
[ __ ] next week fifty four years old I
got nothing going on but you guys you're
the [ __ ] future get up smoke a bowl
do your push-ups get out there tell
these [ __ ] that you're going
for it today it's over you've been
[ __ ] around for the last couple of
years you've been walking around
confused worried about Hillary and all
the other Adele [ __ ] no one you know who
gives a [ __ ] it's time to get down
[ __ ] back down we got some red
for the start off today I'm hittin your
heart today with the presidential from
[ __ ] Sun Center boom and I got this
platinum [ __ ] push from perennial
tremendous you understand me I've
already had my protein shake I've
already written a little bit I'm just
ready for the [ __ ] dad got a meeting
at jujitsu we had a podcast tonight
o'clock with my man Tom Rhodes so you
know always move over like a [ __ ]
shark we'd never stop the understand me
that's the [ __ ] that's what people
understand you wanna you gotta keep
moving all these people want to do this
and be philosophical [ __ ] you gotta
keep moving you go home from here to
there
always keep busy always keep your mind
sharp and it stops you from thinking see
when you think that's when you get in
trouble when you smoke a bone you got it
my future what am I gonna do I don't
give a [ __ ] what you gonna do today is
the only pin you got to think about
today tomorrow who gives a [ __ ] I don't
know nothing about next week people tell
what he's doing I don't know I don't
[ __ ] know all I know is about
[ __ ] today how we're gonna make
it work today who the [ __ ] lunchbox
are we gonna take today how many joints
are we gonna smoke today that's all I'm
worried about
you know me though I keep the [ __ ]
sub-point thank you for keeping socially
unacceptable at number one without you
[ __ ] I have nothing that's why
I do what I do that's why I take the
[ __ ] said that's why we smoke in the
morning to let you [ __ ] know
Uncle Joe ain't one of these fake
[ __ ] it's a drop and [ __ ] ah
and then he ain't living the life you
know me bro
I don't need nobody I don't need a
[ __ ] posse or another that [ __ ] uncle
Joey's a lone wolf with my [ __ ] solo
they sent me in like a seal your thumbs
am NOT the [ __ ] other seals the seals
don't [ __ ] around me anyway besides
that's gonna be a good week I got flat
this Tuesday night we got the ice house
and Joe Rogan Wednesday night I got to
calmly stall with Skylar stall
I got a couple things going on this week
I'm gonna go to jujitsu this week last
week I got caught anything so my jujitsu
went down but I went yesterday I went
last month I'm little three or four
times this week I still suck like I've
been telling you guys for [ __ ] years
I keep showing up because eventually
something Goods gonna happen or
something but does happen even if I get
choked out it's still the [ __ ] good
day of my world he understand me a lot
of people don't look like that way they
get choked out the ego I get choked on
if I last the whole [ __ ] hour I leave
there with a [ __ ] ten-foot dick
because you can't stop that did the
hardest thing I had to do all day that's
the philosophy of it you know Sam oh
yeah Luna didn't get my my tilapia what
that means it it's Monday today's the
day they gotta suck your dick because if
not the rest of the week will be flat
today's the day where you gotta make
your [ __ ] mark and enforce it like
Tony and [ __ ] 84 you follow me
Monday's the dead if you have a shitty
Monday to rest on oh we could be [ __ ]
shitty that's why Monday is very key to
put the week together to plant the right
seeds of yourself man you're calling
people you tell them this got this that
you need generate an excitement it all
hangs on
Monday what you do on Monday [ __ ]
last til Friday you follow me that's why
I'm Mondays I always try to be tip-top
Magoo early my eyes are always gonna be
red you know me Sunday's is the Lord's
Day you got to take that pipe to the
hoop Jack but if you have a good Monday
it sets the assessment president for the
rest of the [ __ ] week that's what my
Mondays I don't [ __ ] around there's no
such thing as Monday blues Monday blues
are for [ __ ]
Monday if you're [ __ ] I don't you
can't wait for [ __ ] Monday amateurs
like though the weekends
listen if you're a [ __ ] savage you
you don't even like weekend you can't
Mondays your favorite day where I am
Monday my [ __ ] dick it's hard I'm
ready establish little plantain cush so
remember what you do on Monday I pose an
eternity forever i gladiator Mondays
your biggest thing right now I'm gonna
stop what I'm doing with you and I go
right the [ __ ] world bank bank
calling people setting them up what do
you want to do when you [ __ ] when
your rims ain't claim you that all
people up right now today set him up but
he's on Thursday but he's always that
and you knock him off balance they get
all confused but they know you're in the
area and they know you're not [ __ ]
around you follow me so if you're
looking for a job today call that
[ __ ] what's up dawg I put the
application in last week I submitted
nothing what's going on is there
anything else you need
Monday's your biggest [ __ ] dinner we
don't like nobody else kitchen I'm tip
top Magoo on [ __ ] Mondays
so Minneapolis next week we got a few
podcast this week and that's it and
that's that we got started on the right
foot write your goals each oatmeal and
you know what all roads lead to get your
dick sucked and ego one way or the other
you know me either you're gonna suck my
dick today are you gonna suck my dick
tomorrow eventually you're gonna suck my
dick which means you gotta be a bus is
gonna [ __ ] come in eventually just
stick to it guys trust me I'm a [ __ ]
stiff I'm a loser I'm a dud and I'm over
here rocking and rolling now why not cuz
I'm better than your [ __ ]
because I struggled with I had nowhere
else to go
I didn't give a [ __ ] I listen to the
negativity how are you not gonna make it
get too old who gives a [ __ ] what's in
your heart is in your heart which in
your balls in your balls this [ __ ] I got
it my balls is strong in the [ __ ]
juice that comes out of a can and you
understand me why cuz I'm a [ __ ]
Savage I'm cut from that [ __ ] it's my
[ __ ] world people always wonder how
these edibles all [ __ ] day I live in
fear but that's the fear 111 does this
when you live in fear where certain type
of fear and you learn to use it to your
advantage
that fear is dangerous it's dangerous
dangerous so you got to be a little
scared no matter what the [ __ ] you do to
keep the passion alive
I mean it's get to smoke this weed
sometimes but what are you gonna do you
will [ __ ] tap out anyway let's do one
more little Bowl I got [ __ ] to do I love
you guys don't forget the podcast at
night eight o'clock
be there or be square I said I love you
guys without you guys look you kept the
album at number one who else does that
for [ __ ] people you people know my
heart is you know I say some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I'm crazy from time to time late
I'm one of those dudes that stared to in
the morning for you with a [ __ ] axe
and a fire battalion hat
[ __ ] rocking I'm saying so work with
me I love you [ __ ] I love you
[ __ ] yeah I'm Sam I love Li
it's just a way of this man least my
little Jewish brother it's the way it is
he's [ __ ] whacked up but I'm stuck
with him and that's the way it's gonna
be till the [ __ ] head into the wheels
floor why because he was there for me in
the beginning I say you gotta do it
people
loyalty is the key you just gotta make
sure you know what the [ __ ] you loyal to
yeah I'm saying I'll be Lord to you
finally gotta be the lawyer to the guy
from Scientology you make the [ __ ]
call [ __ ] anyway keep your eyes
open terrorism is alive and kicking
keep your eyes open just for GP you know
I'm saying cuz you never know I don't
want you in the phone I want you up I
had a pension like a [ __ ] like a
Vietnam vet getting flashbacks uncle
Joey loves you see you tonight 8 o'clock
be there or be square
the church always happened now I have a
great day stay black and go for it -
they don't let nobody [ __ ] stop here
right if you fail you got tomorrow gives
a [ __ ]